This is a very fundamental concept in statistics.
It applies to coin flips and many of the other examples we discussed before.
A candidate in election might have a true chance that any given voter votes for him.
Let's call this chance P, the same as the coin flip, and of course if P larger than 0.5 in a 2% run off
that person will not initially win in most cases, not always, but as a statistician
we can't assess the two chances, so what we do is to form a sample.
In coin flipping, we flip n coins. In elections, we ask n randomly chosen people.
As we know, this gives us an estimated mean.
It gives us also a variance and therefore, standard deviation.
What's new now is the confidence interval, and the confidence interval is not the same as the variance.
In fact, drop the consideration of a variance.
What this says is based on the outcome, we believe for the parameter µ.
This is the best guess we can get, which is usually maximum value estimate,
but we are not quite certain, so you're going to asses a wider range,
in which we believe with high probability that whatever the outcome will be
that the outcome will be high probability within this range.
Very often this range is defined as 95% chance that the final outcome falls into this range.
That will take some work to compute. So let's dive in.